le président macro lui a été toujours
très en retard rappelez vous des
déclarations qu'il faisait au mois
d'octobre et même au mois de décembre
chez vos confrères de brut où il disait
que la possible d'avoir un vaccin était
illusoire que ce qu'ils racontaient ça
franchement n'était pas dans la vérité
je résume un don qu'il a toujours été
très en retard donc nous sixième
puissance mondiale
la france aurait pu faire mieux donc
hélas on a pris du retard - ya une chose
que je voudrais vous dire c'est que le
fait d'avoir pris conscience de tous ces
retards accumulés qui ont été très
préjudiciable à nos compatriotes parce
que si les autres ont misé sur le quoi
qu'il en coûte sur la recherche lui a
fait du quoi qu'il en coûte pour
confiner est bloqué pour le coup notre
économie beaucoup trop longtemps
je pense qu'il faut maintenant anticipé
parce que comme nous ne savons pas
combien de temps à d'efficacité le
vaccin s'il nous faudra nous faire
vacciner comme pour la grippe
j'espère qu'il y à déjà au gouvernement
une anticipation pour prévoir l'année
prochaine
la vaccination si elle doit devenir
annuel pour la france est la première
victime du terrorisme en europe
donc à un moment oui il faut prendre des
mesures extrêmement forte et extrêmement
puissante il faut arrêter ce laxisme et
renvoyés chez eux tous ceux qui sont en
situation illégale
combien de vies auraient été sauvées si
nous avions expulsé ce qui ne devait pas
rester sur notre territoire
je pense aussi vous savez où deux jeunes
filles qui étaient cousines de marseille
qui ont été elles aussi assassiné par
quelqu'un qui ne devait pas se maintenir
sur le territoire
donc c'est la responsabilité de ceux qui
sont au pouvoir quand nos lois ne sont
pas appliquées quand nos mesures ne sont
pas appliquées il ya bien une
responsabilité donc encore une fois
seule la fermeté permettra de ramener la
sécurité dans notre pays